ein monstrum am rande von zürich die
sihlhochstrasse in den fluss gestimmt
unort unbehagen sie stört das nicht
monika rosina jäger nimmt solche orte
auf nicht nur mit der kamera mit ihrem
ganzen körper wie ein schwamm
ich habe über die stadtlandschaft
weisung gibt es ab machen über den
zustand von einer gesellschaft das ist
die große frage
unbehagen ist eine erstattung mich in
bewegung halten
emotional aktivposten im inneren
wahrnehmung und reflexion wirklich blut
und sobald sie mir zu behaglich wird
sollte ich wieder so reizpunkt und das
ist das wo sich kunden staunen
ihre bilder sie entstehen zumeist als
riesige collagen
es sind landschaften in denen man sich
nicht gerne wiederfinden will schon gar
nicht allein
wie in einem science fiction film kommt
uns vieles fremd vor
und doch vertraut
denn alles was die künstlerinnen zu
ihren panoramen zusammenfügt hat sie als
aufmerksame beobachterinnen gefunden
unterwegs in unserer real existierenden
globalisierten welt
die flughafen architektur findet sich
wieder zwischen skurrilen gesteins
formen und fügt sich ein in eine
ziemlich düstere zukunftsvision auf
diese schöpfung passt ein begriff den
monika rosina jäger gerne verwendet wenn
sie ihr werk beschreibt es sind dies
kopien eigentlich ideal zur stand ich
schon erstaunt dann wäre dies geschafft
wo im schlechten zustand ist der wald wo
sich zum zum negativen entwickelt
klingt so als bringe sie damit unser
gefühl am anfang dieses jahres auf einen
nenner stets zieht es die künstlerin an
die ränder der städte oder schön
schaurige landschaftsbild nahrung findet
doch auch ihre sehnsucht nach utopischen
entwürfen es zu spüren
oft finden wir puzzlestücke auszeiten
die strotzten vor optimismus die 60er
und 70er jahre etwa als man etwas naiv
meinte alles sei möglich
mit der richtigen technik der richtigen
architektur utopie und disco in diesen
bildern kann das eine jederzeit ins
andere geschlagen
ich glaube die fiel ambivalent
platzierte wo man so hin und her ist es
inzwischen fertig und pessimismus und
mir beim besten willen nicht ausmalen
wie es damit wirklich gut tun und
gleichzeitig aber durchaus wille handels
freut
ganz zum schluss zeichnet monika rosina
jäger ihre collagierten welten in
chinesischer schwarzer tusche
was aus hunderten inspirationsquellen
zusammenfand zerfließt nun zur
landschaft
was bilder auslösen können diese frage
hat sie sich nach dem schock des
attentats auf charlie hebdo noch einmal
intensiver gestellt
wie viele die heute bilder in die welt
bringen
was sind dann die bilder ist das ist es
ist es dank bis zur 15 jahre ist es im
schlimmsten fall im profi und was heißt
das wenn ich dir die bilder sind
die künstlerinnen die schwarz malt sie
ist seismographen für ein kollektives
befinden
in einer verunsicherten welt